on a tiré au bazooka contre le ministère
des transports un homme et une femme ont
déchargé leurs armes sur la façade du
ministère de la coopération lui balles à
bout portant de en pleine tête les eaux
dans le corps patron de la régie a été
assassiné au moment même où il rentrait
chez
action directe et et après mesrine
l'ennemi public numéro un
[Musique]
action directe c'est un groupe d'auto
nos qui entend par la lutte armée
renverser l'état capitaliste entre 79
date de sa création et 87 l'arrestation
de son chef jean marc rouillan de sa
compagne nathalie ménigon et joëlle
aubron et de georges cipriani de
l'action directe comme et 80 attentat
sur le sol français donc c'est quand
même énorme toutes organisations se
réclamant d'une idéologie politique qui
instaurera la violence en système sera
poursuivie dissoute interdite
et les membres seront pourchassés
arrêtés condamnés j'ai des souvenirs
très précis quand j'allais au lycée en
métro de voir les affichettes avec les
quatre visages des quatre derniers
d'action directe n'avait pas encore été
capturé
[Musique]
joëlle aubron elle m'a intéressé parce
qu'elle a un parcours qui n'est pas
celui des autres membres d'action
directe les autres membres d'action
directe viennent de milieux extrêmement
défavorisés ils ont été déscolarisés
très tôt ils sont souvent en rupture
familiale depuis
depuis leur jeunesse alors que joëlle
aubron c'est une
une fille qui nous manquait de rien
elle est née à neuilly dans une famille
soudée et menthe avec suffisamment
d'argent pour lui offrir une école
privée avec un château de famille et moi
ce qui m'a intéressé en tant que
romancière c'était justement
qu'est-ce qui a bien pu dû passer par la
tête et qu'est ce qui a bien pu faire
pour que cette jeune fille qui a eu une
enfance tout à fait normal bascule dans
ce groupuscule révolutionnaire jusqu'à
prendre les armes demandées à se former
aux armes et se porter volontaire pour
l'assassinât de personnalités civiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le ou les meurtriers n'ont laissé aucune
chance à rené audran quelqu'un on voit
la corderie
évident charger de 11,43 lui balles à
bout portant de en pleine tête les
autres dans le corps le haut
fonctionnaire s'effondre il est mort sur
le coup
[Musique]
sous une feuille de plastique blanc le
corps de georges besse le pdg de renault
le patron de la régie a été assassiné au
moment même où il rentrait chez lui
georges mais c'est un grand pas trop
respectés
il est proche de beaucoup de monde du
gouvernement c'est un père de famille
qui considérait comme avoir bien géré
ses boîtes donc ça crée énormément
d'émotion et surtout
la police et le gouvernement français
comprend que action directe ne va pas
s'arrêter là et va continuer à commettre
des assassinats
il ya eu d'autres alertes à une bombe
posée sous la voiture du garde des
sceaux en tuant le chauffeur pouvons pas
lutter contre eux avec des méthodes
ordinaires sont obligés d'employer tous
les moyens à leur disposition
[Musique]
c'était des affiches un peu à
l'américaine avec de grosses récompenses
qui était promise à qui donnerait des
informations pour leur capture
[Musique]
sont beaucoup plus près parce que la
police pensait ils sont nés en allemagne
au bout du monde ils sont dans le loiret
donc tout proche de paris dans une ferme
qui sont noués sous des faux noms sont
très insérées localement puisque ça fait
deux ans et demi qui sont là donc les
gens du village les connaissent les
invite à boire l'apéro et amener souvent
contraire les vaches à lait du monde
parce qu'elle commande avait dit petit
chai pas dit quand ils ont leur petit
que chaque trêve lemay chef et amener le
choix pour traire mes vaches avec moi
que j montre l'étau se resserre et une
fois que la police les a identifiés il
va avoir un assaut du raid assez
spectaculaire c'est cette ferme qui
étaient prises d'assaut samedi soir sur
place 50 hommes du raid unité d'élite de
la police commandé par le commissaire
ange mancini ils sont tous vêtus de noir
et portaient des cagoules samedi matin
il voit passer une jeune femme s'est
peut-être nathalie ménigon mais en
quatre ans de clandestinité elle a
changé un indice valeur confirmer son
identité la jeune femme est allée
acheter des graines pour des hamsters or
nathalie ménigon et passionné par ces
petits animaux à 20h55 l'assaut ménigon
et aubron et cipriani surpris ne résiste
pas briand tente de s'emparer d'une arme
les policiers tirent en l'air et le
capture dans la ferme des armes de
l'argent et des documents mais aussi une
liste de personnalités à enlever ou à
tuer une caisse de la ferme avait
d'ailleurs été spécialement aménagée en
prison populaire pour y détenir l'une de
ces personnalités joëlle aubron comme
les autres les trois autres qui auraient
été arrêtées avec m
manifesteront jamais aucun regret ni
aucune forme de compassion envers leurs
victimes j'assume le terme de terroriste
comme les résistants pendant la dernière
guerre est hétéro et c'est aussi voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la libération de mes camarades est une
bataille toujours en cours
[Musique]
si je dis
je regrette
c'est vraiment
faire la donner la part belle au
vainqueur en 10 ans mais il avait raison
continuer nous massacrer et puis après
on voudrait viendra tous pleuré dans
votre girons parce que on regrette très
très fort je veux dire de ne pas avoir
été aussi soumis
que vous le souhaitiez et ça il n'en est
pas question